من بعد كل التطور اللي بنعيشه في كل
النواحي وخاصه في التكنولوجيا والهواتف
الذكيه من كانت تخيل انه في يوم من الايام
راح ترجع الهواتف الغبيه الى الواجهه مو
بس ترجع للوجه لا كمان تصير ترند في كل
العالم كمان واللي مفاجاه حقيقه انه الجيل
الجديد اللي ما يعرف الا الهواتف الذكيه
او انه يعني التسكرين والمتاجر
الالكترونيه اللي مليانه بالتطبيقات هم
جزء اساسي من هذا الترند وبيبدله
تليفوناتهم ذكيه بتلفونات قديمه ومميزات
اقل وشركه نوكيا اللي يوم من الايام كانت
الرقم واحد في بيعه التليفونات اذا تتذكره
في مرحله ما قبل ما تخرج منها البساط
تليفونات الاندرويد والايفون نوكيا كشفوا
الاسبوع الماضي انهم راجعين للسوق وبقوه
وانه السنه الماضيه استعاده جزء كبير من
وجودهم في السوق طيب اللي بيتزا قال طيب
ايش السبب اللي خلى الهواتف القديمه ترجع
تتصدر الاسباب كثيره لكن كلها بتدور في
فلك واحد وهو الضغط اللي بتعملوا علينا
هذه التليفونات والتطبيقات اللي عليها
سواء منصات التواصل تطبيقات الاخبار
الالعاب تطبيقات المراسله الفوريه طبعا
الواتساب وغيره وغيره طبعا من الامور في
الواحد صاير طول الوقت فعليا يبقى يعرف كل
شيء وما يبغى يفوتوا اي شيء هذا غير
متابعه الاخبار اللي بتزيد عن حدها اوقات
ومنصات التواصل اللي معاها كمان بتزيد
المقارنه مع الاخرين واحساس الواحد انه
الثانيين احسن منه فالناس بدات الترم هذه
التليفونات باللي فيها وترجع لتليفونات
بتتصل وتبعث رسائل نصيه بسيطه وفيها كم
لعبه بدائيه وشكرا ما تبغى اي شيء اضافي
خلاص تفضل خلينا نتكلم شويه عن هذا
الموضوع او نحاول نفهم معانا من الرياض
صانع المحتوى التقني فيصل السيف اهلا فيك
معنا همم فيصل لاي درجه فعلا يعني واصل
الوضع انه نرجع لها التليفون يعني
يا اهلا وسهلا فيك مساكم الله بالخير جميع
الوضع صار صعب في بعض المناطق بعض الدول
وايضا مع بعض الافراد فعشان كده المغرب
الوحيد يمكن ان اخذ قسط من الراحه من
الجوالات الذكيه والانتقال لهذه الجوالات
التي سميتها غبيه
يعني غبيه اللي بنستعمله اليوم
تحس انها تطورت عمرها ومن ناحيه البطاريه
والشاشه والى الحين للتوضيح ترى الجوالات
الاقتصاديه اللي من هذا النوع هي من
الاكثر انتشارا في العالم بالذات يتكلم عن
بعض الدول لماذا زالت البنيه التحتيه في
الاتصالات
الذكيه بشكل مستمر هذه الجوالات ما هرب
ممتاز للحصول على جوال تستخدمه
نوكل الان لما بيقولوا انه فعلا اخذين
راجعين اخذين حصه من السوق تعتقد بسبب هذا
الموضوع تحديدا
اولا نتوقع ان الموضوع كمان لما نوكيا
قالوا كانه في جانب تسويق نوكيا ليست بحجم
الماضي ابدا ابدا ما هي زي زمان فبالتالي
ما لهم الحصه السوقيه الضخمه الحصه
السوقيه ابخن عن شركات اخرى هم لما يقولوا
بدات تتحسن هذه النتائج عندنا من ناحيه
المبيعات فما قاعدين نتكلم على معرض
الصغير موجود عندهم في السوق شيء يمكن
يقدروا من خلاله يحاولوا يجيبوا زخم
الاعلام بشكل قوي وايضا نظيفه الى ذلك
انهم قطاع نفسه بحق ذاته ما هو بيعتبر لا
مليار له ملياري ولا اكثر من كده من ناحيه
الوسط فبالتالي بتلاقي دائما حتى عندنا في
الخليج في المناطق العربيه هذا الجوال هل
ثانوي حسن جدا ممتاز انه دائما معه الناس
اللي حولنا قدام اللي عندهم اعمال يوميا
بشكل مستمر اعمال صعبه هذا الجوال هو
المهرب اللي استخدمه خلال العمل والجوالات
الذكيه هذه ارجعها في البيت
اللي شايله فعلا جوال يعني بس كده يت
ويستقبل طيب الان اا بيقولوا الناس كمان
في ترن ثاني انهم رجعوا لهذه التليفونات
لانه كاميراتها ما هي بجوده الكاميرات
الجديده في الصور بتطلع كانها مفلتره ما
تحسنت الكاميرات ههه
لا تحسي عشان اريحك يا تحسنت
الكاميرون
حكم السعر حقها فطبيع الحال لما تدفع سعر
عالي 1000 ريال وفوق هتلاقي انه قطع نفسها
المستخدمه هتعطي جوده افضل بكثير من هذه
الجوالات اوكي نعم
تتطورت ولكن ما زالت تعتبر جدا بدائيه ليش
لانه ما فيها تطبيقات ونظام تشغيل وانتشر
زي اللي احنا عارفين اذا ما في تطبيق
لانه كل الاشياء اللي انت بتتكلم عنها هذه
اشياء اساسيه يعني همم جوجل مابس لو انا
ضايعه لو بدي ادخل مثلا من البنك اشياء زي
كده يعني هقدر حتى لو بدي صحه النفسيه
تتحسن
النفسيه تتحسن حبي نمط الطيران شوي وبعدين
شغل الجوال
اللي كان موجود الرسائل الثانيه وانت حاطه
انا انت بتسوي كده
ونام حتى الحين في خصائص
برده
[ضحك]
اقل من كفاءه التطبيقات وتصير التطبيق
عنيه يتحمل ابطا شويه فبالتالي هتلاقي
نفسك مليت من الجواهر
النوم هذا لانه اصلا يعني عشان اوصل اقنع
نفسي اني اسوي كده يعني هذه مرحله متقدمه
على العموم شكرا لك
على المحتوى التقرير فيصل شكرا لك